The economy is in bad shape and it's
gonna stay in bad shape for a while.
He kind of feeds on itself.
There are fewer jobs over whether a few
people will spending money.
Therefore everybody's reach retracting
and,
and then this is a smaller profit.
So they let people go at it.
He goes on and on until finally somebody
like Roosevelt comes along and says,
you got nothing to fear but fear itself.
And then fortunately he was a World War
II came along and I read a basic
recovery of the business.
Well,
I don't think that I wanted a world war,
uh,
to rejuvenate our economy.
So we're going to have to learn to do it
ourselves.
Now,
fortunately,
uh,
we're in a,
in a very global world and you know,
I already nixed,
takes one engine,
uh,
to get the thing going again this time
the engine will probably be,
uh,
the Far East,
China and India.
But you know,
we also have to learn how to police
ourselves.
We have to say,
no,
that's not the right thing to do.
I'm not going to do it.
And until the majority of businessmen
are the big majority,
bismuth say that we're still going to
have the same sort of problems we have
recurring.